so today's video is a little bit
left-field of what we usually talk about
on this channel but if you want to look
forward some good technology you need to
be making a decent amount of income so
today we're gonna be talking about how
you can double if not triple your annual
salary and savings every single year
without fail what's going on guys my
name is David Tommy and welcome back to
the channel
all right so in the mail we got
something pretty cool today that
actually I have no idea how this came
about but it forms one of my 10 passive
incomes so I thought about not talking
about it on this video and then talking
about on this video and I thought it's
probably a good thing that I do talk
about it on this video and tell you guys
straight up that this box is in no way
shape or form sponsored it's genuinely
just a company sending me some free
stuff to take a look at and give you my
honest review the benefit of this is
however that the company in question is
cuts clothing cuts clothing is something
that I've warned for a couple of years
now and it is pretty good quality stuff
so when they reached out and they said
they wanted to partner up again we've
partnered off before on Instagram check
me out on Instagram if you haven't
already that was pretty much a
no-brainer for me because I know this
that's good I know I wear it all the
time and it's not going to just sit in
the cupboard like a whole bunch of other
stuff I get from different companies so
cuts clothing let's take a look at
what's inside this box so this is a bit
of a different angle from anger I think
I'm standing up so it's a little bit
awkward too but let's take a look what's
inside the fantastic cuts clothing box
so if you haven't noticed already one of
the shirt I was wearing throughout this
whole video and for most of my previous
videos I'm being honest with you guys
has been from cuts clothing so very
simple very elegant designs super
buttery soft material that hugs your
arms quite nicely does have a curved
little hem and a little cross feature at
the bottom so overall high quality
minimalistic shirt which is one of my
favorite thing long-sleeve shirt because
even though I do live in Australia I
live in a very cold part of Australia so
with another round of him
whoa it's like 20 degrees in summer and
actually quite cold so I like to have
some long-sleeved shirts laying around
when I can and finally a perfect white
shirt with another split hem and though
I claim X at the bottom there is one
thing I dislike about these shows guys
and it does mean it comes with a tag at
the bottom I do rip this tag off every
time I get a new shirt and if you want
to save 15% there's a link down below
check it out help me make some passive
income and let's get on with this video
okay
so let's dive into how you can actually
double if not triple your baseline
income on a yearly basis I'm not gonna
throw numbers at you guys here instead
I'm gonna throw percentages because at
the end of the day it doesn't matter if
you're making $10,000 a year a hundred
thousand dollars a year or ten million
dollars a year the principle is exactly
the same because you're going to be
investing the same amount of time the
same amount of energy into the same
things for me this has developed over a
course of maybe three years and it's led
me to the point at this stage where I
can honestly say it does maybe about
double and a half of my yearly income
which is pretty good stuff so if we
start with the job itself most of you
I'm hoping will have a job and not just
try to start a side hustle as you main
hustle the thing that most people get
wrong here is they go straight for the
side hustle they put all their energy
and all their effort into it which is
don't get me wrong fantastic and you
should be putting a lot of energy into
it but they rely solely on that side
hustle you need to be able to support
the side hustle hence why it is called a
side hustle so without any of these
active or passive incomes I'm about to
talk about your job is going to make you
100 percent of your financial savings
and your income for the year if we take
30 percent of that for realistic tax
purposes for most people starting out
you left with about 70 percent again
take another 20 to 30 percent for living
expenses food bills things like that
going out catching up with friends
you're down to about 40 percent
your total income that you can save so
great we're starting off with 40 percent
of your income which if you're able to
say 40 percent you're doing pretty well
now for me I'm relatively lucky that
inside my job there's passive and active
incomes that contribute over and above
my salary itself so for me I actually
have a job inside my job which is
exactly the same as what I do in my job
but it's for a superior company this
makes me an additional five percent of
my income throughout the year and then
inside my job again
I have commission based bonuses so if I
bring in clients to design houses or
commercial buildings I get a small
Commission of that and that makes me
another five to ten percent on top of my
income as it stands these are two things
that you might not have in every job and
if you do well then you're probably a
little bit lucky and two steps ahead of
everybody else but if you don't that's
completely okay because the next eight
steps I'm going to talk about have
nothing to do with your job itself
my first passive income is a very basic
and very boring one it's actually the
interest you earn from a high interest
bank account for me at the moment a high
interest bank account is two percent
which is below inflation inflation sits
at about three percent so you also want
to be looking at making sure your money
grows more than three percent every year
the bank account did used to earn 3% at
the start of the year but the economy
continues to go down and continues to go
down with it hence why it's up 2% mark
but if your money is just sitting in a
normal bank account earning zero
interest well then you're actually
losing money in the grand scheme of
things whereas if you have it in a high
interest savings account and you're
making two three percent back then
that's definitely one way to make a
little bit of passive income on the side
the next form of passive income for me
is actually dividend stocks and dividend
trading if you don't know what dividend
trading is basically it's when you buy
stocks in a company such as Apple or any
of the big banks that give you some of
their profit at the end of the quarter
at the end of the month at the end of
the year depending on each individual
stock so for most banks here in
Australia you get a
five to eight percent dividend interest
on your investment so if you don't
$10,000 in a bank for example over the
year you could get up to eight hundred
dollars in return for no real reason
other than you purchased those shares a
year ago you sat with them you made some
money and hopefully the share price
didn't actually go less hopefully it
went up and you made some more on top of
that and if that dividend share does go
up over the course of a year and say
it's gone up a phenomenal 20 percent
that brings me to my next point which is
actual share market trading so share
market trading can actually be a really
good investment if you know what you're
doing and you're educated I would highly
recommend doing some research on
anything trading related anything stock
related before you dive into the deep
end of it and throw all your money in
and probably lose all your money because
it is a volatile market that can go
south really really quickly if you don't
know what you're doing however if you do
know what you're doing there's potential
is to make endless amounts of money so
at the moment I'll have my little cheat
sheet here because too many things and
too many numbers to remember your job
gets you 40% your job inside your job
gets you another 5% your commission on
top of your job inside your job in your
job gets you another 5% so we set up 50%
of the income their interest in the bank
account plus your dividends gets you
another 10 percent 2% interest
8% dividends roughly give or take your
shares gets you another 15% so here
already we've gone up to what 50 60 75
percent of your actual dividend of your
actual income sorry so straight away
we're almost doubling our income before
we get into any e-commerce
entrepreneurial style of businesses on
the side that you can spend some time on
moving on to the next subject of
e-commerce which is a very big beast in
its own learning ecommerce and learning
trading are two very different things
but basically ecommerce is something
that again you have to do a lot of
research on learn every single thing
about
the ins and the outs before you get into
and waste your money but if you know
what you're doing you can make a little
bit of money on the side here as well so
for me personally I have two ecommerce
related stores I have one that deals
with fashion accessories and another one
that's an actual physical rental store
here in Australia both of those make me
hmm yeah five percent of one ten percent
on the other so a total of fifteen
percent between these two ecommerce
related stores if you're thinking that
my income itself only makes me forty
percent and these two make me fifteen
percent that's almost half of my savings
alone that I'm able to save saved in
addition into e-commerce stores so
running an e-commerce store on the side
is a fantastic way to make a little bit
of extra money moving on to the passive
income number eight which is well what I
kind of do here sitting and talking to a
camera and hoping that a few people
watch it and click it and enjoy the
videos basically for every video I
produce there's ads at the start
sometimes is ads in the middle I try to
avoid that if I can and there's an ad at
the end which is basic YouTube algorithm
stuff it makes me a little bit of money
it does not make me a lot of money
hence the subscribe account so if you
are watching it and have gotten this far
make sure you smash that subscribe
button help me out smash the like button
that way I can make a little bit of more
money and the 5% that I make off youtube
throughout the year can maybe rise to
10% if I'm lucky
but basically YouTube ads makes me
another five percent of my income which
is good to know from the grand scheme of
things that I haven't been wasting my
last year seeing on YouTube talking to a
camera for no other reason then because
I had an extra couple of hours in my
week
ix source of passive income for me isn't
it isn't really a passive income yet
because I don't count it as anything
until it's really hit my bank account
but basically underneath every single
video I try to put some Amazon affiliate
links to the stuff I use in the video to
stuff I talked about and last month and
made
total of seven dollars and 41 cents
which never got into my bank account so
I don't count it as a passive income
however it is something that does
accumulate and does grow so eventually
this Amazon affiliate links will become
a genuine source of passive income for
me currently it's zero percent but one
day it will definitely turn into a
tangible percentage that I will be able
to include in a video like this and last
but not least it is Instagram promotions
and YouTube promotions so very similar
to the sort of advertising you saw at
the start of this video from Cutts
clothing I do a lot of Instagram based
content creation for companies all
around Australia and the world I find
most of my companies on an app called
tribe if you're not on there that's cool
you need I think 3000 subscribers
to start building up on tribe and then
you can work your way through it's not
too difficult to get 3000 subscribers in
this day and age I think if it's
something that you set your mind to and
you begin posting begin engaging and
trying to build up a following that way
you can actually earn a pretty decent
amount of money so for example I will
give you a dollar figure here this isn't
with cuts it's got nothing to do with
them it was a simple photo I took for
another company that was paid a hundred
and fifty dollars for one photo the
photo took me maybe 15 minutes to put
together another five minutes to edit
and I got some free stuff along the way
so realistically I probably got 150
dollars worth of product plus $150 of
actual paid physical income into my bank
account per photo that I took I do not
to many of these because I like to still
keep my Instagram grid a little bit
genuine about my life and about what I
do so it doesn't add up to too much but
it is something that can easily and I
mean very easily make you a couple
thousand dollars every single year by
just posting here and there so for me
Instagram paid promotions and YouTube
pay promotions adds up to another five
percent of my passive income
so if we take a look a quick recap 40%
comes from my actual job 60% comes from
all the different passive sources of
income that I have that means overall I
double my income very easily and very
quickly well that's not true there's
quite a lot of hard work that goes into
it and you have to be willing to come
home from work finish your job come back
into your home office and keep working
late into the night
there is absolutely no such thing as a
quick easy fix and a quick easy get rich
scheme if anybody is telling you that
and they are lying to your face so avoid
it do not look at it actually try and
educate yourself on a particular topic
be it stock market trading day trading
ecommerce retail high or whatever it is
YouTube Instagram it doesn't matter
educate yourself on something stick with
it for a solid six months and learn
everything there is to it apply it get
good at it if you don't like it move on
to the next thing but basically the
purpose of this video is the fact that
you can't just go ahead and double your
income with one stream of a different
company or a different idea well if
you're lucky or if you're extremely good
at what you do then yes 100% and you can
make that your genuine source of
full-time income all the big youtubers
with hundreds and 100s with tens of
millions of subscribers full-time no
questions asked they're making a couple
hundred thousand dollars easily a few
tube ads alone and then they've probably
also got their own stores their own
merchandise which you guys probably buy
into which makes them another couple
hundred thousand dollars and they're
pretty much rolling in it and that's
their full-time job because it requires
all their attention if they wanted to go
and do some dividend trading they could
easily make another five to ten percent
on top of their money but not
everybody's into that sort of stuff
they're not into the risks basically
make sure you set up a whole array of
different passive incomes that you can
sustain that you can stay on top of and
hopefully one day you'll easily be able
to double if not
triple your income from your job that's
all for me guys thank you so much for
watching I hope you enjoyed the video if
you did smash subscribe button down
below
tap the like button and drop a comment
if you want to know anything else about
the numbers the categories or anything I
spoke about today I try to reply to
everybody if you're a troll I don't
really worry about you just leave you be
to do your own thing but yeah genuine
comments will be replied to and I try to
engage with you as much as possible so
thanks again for watching and as always
I'll see you next Monday